what is this guys if
we don't post any memes for a week
pewdiepie will be forced to
do original content
you think i'm scared of you
nine-year-olds let's review
the memes leave your entries in the
subreddit crows
and i'll watch submissions in the next
episode of floyd
hmm what is this delhi
this now i love this meme it just keeps
on living
i miss i mean you know what i miss them
that's the weirdest thing
that's right i'm not afraid to tell
people the world how did
lp know a man's hands were purple when
he was wearing his collar blind glass
look the reason why pure news is the
most underrated nude stars on the
internet
it's in the wrong category wait it's in
gaming
are you kidding me psy what do you do
with
you put it as gaming penis is not a game
it's a serious
oh this is so embarrassing
never getting erased now guys i like the
idea of not posting memes for a week so
beards will have to make original cut
stop it is this going to be all of it
now memes about not making original
content
is memes which is giving me original
jokes on you t he said
without you guys i wouldn't be here but
little does he know without him
most of us wouldn't be here that is the
mopiest
trash i have ever heard what thanks to
some youtuber
that's right i indirectly gave birth to
64 million kids
that's a lot of sperm hope sees this
so he start playing it detroit become
human all right enough fine
if this video if this video
gets five hundred
thousand likes i will play detroit
become
human just because this gameplay looks
absolutely
lit invent football decide its rules
invest millions of pounds watch everyone
play better than you
it's coming home no it isn't you dummy
country why am i here
why do i hate england hit him with the
silence nine year olds
start with on 20 spread awareness 20
oh so it's starting next week oh so he
could actually work
oh no i'm shaking guys i'm shaking
i'm so scared you can't live without the
memes just like i can't live without
non-original content we're in this
together damn it
stop pretending like you're better than
me when you see how
big his headphone cable is that's right
everybody i
told you about my razor headphones
that's right they got really
what's great about these that they got
extremely low
for the headphones i could just walk
anywhere it's incredible
and i'm just keep walking i'm just gonna
keep one look how far away i
am they're also 3.99 which is a great
price why is my sister named rose
because your mother likes roses thanks
steve no problem
the idea of not posting memes for a week
so pirates will have to make original
content
oh i'm sorry lol liking the idea of not
posting memes for a week but then using
the idea meme to make a meme which
contradicts your liking this is me
inception wow
this is this is truly woke i am
impressed
whoa that is really creepy and weird
what the actual it's cool but ugh
yucky you laugh you lost
good one good one when you tell a
slightly offensive joke in a video
pewds subscribers newcomers
news media accurate well done an
accurate meme
looking for lawyer content guys i like
the idea of not posting memes for a week
because it will have to make
stop it what is this meta meme it's so
weird
i just made a new meme i hope the bros
like it
guys i like the idea of not posting
memes for a week
so peers will have to make original
content the meta meme on this
it's off the charts man fortnight
players petitioned to add ability
to thank the bus driver before jumping
why can't you do that
so disrespectful i don't understand why
anyone plays this game
but but he's about to say his first word
but ain't my gonna
i get it that was clever please felix
can you have martial host meme review
punisher or lewis just one epic
you guys really want to get rid of me
don't you it's so nice
to have an audience that doesn't turn
against you and want other people to
appear on my channel
desperately it's very nice i i love i
love this this is great
all right you've been doing this seven
years now can someone else can someone
else take over please
good evening i'm erin burnett and i'm
the new host
of pew news first story where is
poppy harlow some suspect she traveled
forward through time
to stop this from happening suck your
mom
suck your mom suck your mom suck your
mama
most ambitious projects ever khalifa
tower 29
mars exploration program 2012 pewdiepie
subreddit 2018.
guys i like the idea of not posting
memes for one week so peers will have to
make original content
let's start this with 20 to 27 spread
awareness
by posting this until then let's spread
the awareness everyone
let's make sure everyone gets this
message that i like the idea of not
posting memes
for a week so peers will have fine you
think i can't do it
if this is a challenge i won't do the
why next suit i don't need this
i gotta make a bridge out of my sound
waves
felix chalberg announces bridge two
it's gonna be great
used to be simpler times you could just
say whatever you wanted
by order of the 90 year old army we will
not post memes
starting the 20th to 27th so you will
have to make original content
are you threatening me man you repair me
the subreddit will decide your fate
i am yes i'm ready not yet
it's recently make fun of little kids
week two yes
don't think i won't do it i'm looking at
you little children
we need to collect all the promises he
made i will that's so cute
i'm like the worst youtuber ever i say
that's gonna do so much
i need to stop making pride i want to
it's cute where do i get paper from i
don't know where you get paper
crazy you guys are crazy you're asking
for way too much of me
okay i'm already looking at funny
pictures it's hard enough here
okay longest things on earth the great
wall
the knight the queen by one bridge
the cable of these headphones
3.99 honestly how much did they actually
cost
99.99 that's a great price
xxx tentacion donated
15 did he really that'd be so sick
i don't think he did either way rest in
peace
xxx pewdiepie submissions guys
i like the idea of not posting memes for
one week
peers yeah
honestly i want to do more dr phil but i
fee
i feel like it's too far some some of
them are just
deranged children and i'm literally just
making fun of them
it was fun for a while but if i make it
a thing
i'll just look like a an idiot come on
man come on come on
come on you can do this is what it's
like living in the same houses
and this is a full size so you get tons
of product the first time i tried this i
instantly thought that it smelled like
summer
and it must be the kelp obviously but
it's just not
so refreshing
good meme dr sandwich it's official
we're the dumbest civilization ever
people are donating money to kylie
jenner to help her become the world's
youngest female billionaire
oh yeah because she's evaluated to like
900 million or something
to help her become the world's youngest
female billionaire
how how how does she have so much i
don't get it
girlfriend no girlfriend marzia
i'm not saying this is true but look
inside my wallet
no
i need to do a meme review on this meme
i think it's time for it to go i think
it's time for this to just go away
uh i love how it doesn't need anything
it's just
it's like the new lost meme you know oh
l l i read a comment where's her left
hand
hmm macy pewdiepie after thanking the
bus driver
geez yeah this man slaps your bus
driver's ass
what do you do guys i like the idea of
not
[ __ ]
i'm so confused why is this a mean sir
you've been in a coma since 2013. this
year is
2018. oh boy i can't wait to see my
favorite youtuber
playing video games fine i'm gonna play
it all right i'll play beyond or
whatever it's called
such a dumb name elon musk presents how
hyperloop will be designed huh
that's cool that's it for this week's of
law and next week's as well that's right
thank you guys so for watching this
video leaving a like
hit subscribe if you're not already and
submit a meme in the pewdiepie subreddit
join the community have some fun and
i'll see you guys
not next week bye no brof is for you
forget about it i know you're just here
for the ass outro anyway
[Music]
oh
you